[Musique]
120 jours voilà cent vingt jours que
nous parcourons cette région voilà cent
vingt jours que quotidiennement jeu
vient à votre rencontre
voilà cent vingt jours que nous faisons
levée dans cette région une nouvelle
espérance
voilà cent vingt jours de courage de
clarté de détermination d'ambition pour
l'avenir 120 jours 120 jours pour nous
mener à la victoire que nous attendons
donc les combats difficiles
il en a l'habitude il a la jeunesse des
tempéraments l'énergie c'est le candidat
qu'il faut pour l'occitanie il est
courageux il entraîne il a du talent il
a de l'énergie aie
il n'est pas une valeur montante le lot
dans l'histoire a souvent eu des gens
qui auront bouleversé le pays il fait
partie de ceux qui pourraient venir
ne vous privez pas d' équipe de talent
conduite par un homme de talent est
attentif à l'occitanie comme il est
attentif à la france je veux lancer un
appel solennel aux électeurs de la
droite est puissante
ils sont des six en présentant aux
raiders brasier nous offrons quelque
chose de nouveau à 7 kg
je forme le voeu et je suis venu le dire
aujourd'hui que demain va l'occitanie
fred un nouveau destin avec aurélien
radeef la droite républicaine
l année il s'appelle le courage cet
avenir
je n'ai jamais trahi et une seule
seconde mais conditions vous avez devant
vous et partout dans cette région 184
candidats qui ne travailleront pas je
vous appelle à la mobilisation
chaque voix comptera nous ferons la
différence il y à ici en occitanie une
nouvelle génération qui aspire demain à
prendre des responsabilités il ici en
occitanie une nouvelle génération qui
sait ce qu'est le courage ce qu'est la
détermination et ce qu'est la fidélité
français valeur il a des valeurs
il le prouve il est entouré de gens de
qualité c'est vraiment le candidat a des
convictions le candidat des valeurs
voûte et les plaisirs reviendra et on va
mobiliser pour aurélien pradié le 27
juin je vais voter pour aurélien pradié
toute notre équipe et mauguio carnon
vote aura pour aurélien pradié les 20 et
27 juin prochains donc les 27 juin
votons tous
aurélien pradié voter aurélien pradié le
27 juin je vais voter pour rien prédire
belgrade et ça va être super présidente
de région les 20 et 27 juin
j'ai besoin de vous les 20 et 27 juin
les 183 candidats qui m'entourent dans
chacun des départements notre région ont
besoin de votre mobilisation les 20 et
27 juin
soyez au rendez-vous de cette espérance
qui nous attend
[Musique]